hey guys how you doing Gary here just
hanging out came to a finally a good
thought that I wanted to put on Gary
vinegar calm and kind of recaps a lot of
what I've been doing but before I do I
just want to point to this that is a joe
namath statue made out of tin foil I'll
give it a little more play later anyway
I want to talk to you about PHCC PHCC is
uh is a really the core a wrap up of
what I've been thinking about with a
Gary Vaynerchuk calm over the last
couple months the things I've been
talking about things I've been
interacting with you guys with and so
many people are asking me different
questions I figured I'd wrap it up in a
ball and make this video you know listen
I was born in Belarus the former Soviet
Union so I come from the land of four
letters you know USSR cccp you know I
come from that land so it's probably
proper that I've got a four-letter
thought process PHCC what does it stand
for what does it mean and how does it
affect you but to me the the world is
changing right word of mouth is
exploding the tools we're using whether
it's Twitter or you know Facebook or
whatever it may be friendfeed pounds
beyond and beyond um and it's going to
continue to keep going seesmic these are
ways to communicate on a global level
and the word gets traveled right I mean
it just continues to travel I mean the
biggest socialite in New York how many
people could she possibly tell 10 years
ago right so weird of mouth is on
steroids so taking that into
consideration every brand every person
and I mean personal brand I mean you
know coca-cola Green Mountain Coffee
every business that there's a changing
platform the gatekeepers are changing
and so that's very important to
understand so PHCC P stands for patients
way too many people in this space are
not patient everyone's like why isn't it
happening I've been doing this for six
months are you kidding me you're
building a business I mean all these
terms that people arguing a social media
dead no such thing as social me who
cares it's business we're in America
economics you know this is a capitalist
country it's business when you build a
business things don't normally happen in
six months my friends promise you it's a
long career for me it started with
lemonade stands when I was five still
some principles i use so it takes time
when you're building a bit
so if you're doing a podcast or you're
doing a web app and you don't have a lot
of traction after six months you know
please understand what you're going for
you have to have patience the
gatekeepers the people that are spending
the advertising dollars right now are
not totally wrapped around this face and
rightfully so it still have you know the
new metrics they need to figure it out
they're not sure exactly when you're not
positive about something you don't jump
in oh here's a pool why is the water
purple I don't know jump in you know
that's how they do it you can hold them
stupid but they still run big businesses
and they kind of know what they're doing
because honestly i agree with you to
spend twenty thousand dollars on a
newspaper ad or you know on a magazine
ad or on a you know a radio ad is just
not quite as smart if you really delve
into social media web 20 all the crap
whatever you call it you know there's a
lot of opportunity a lot of
opportunities for the advertisers but
that's another story but what you have
to wrap your head around is the number
two you know that lovely lady in the
office that's 34 years old she knows
what's up guys you know her you've met
her at the conferences she's gonna be
primed and she's gonna be ready in two
years to make the buying decisions for
this global company and guess what
you're gonna start seeing the benefits
you're gonna get started getting offers
so see keep doing your thing and that's
where the second part that's why it
starts with a be you need the patients
but here comes the hcc the next point is
h hustle you've heard me talk about
hustle two point oh it goes back you've
got to work your face off that's the
bottom line folks you've got to work
really hard and you've got to continue
to commit to your product but you've got
hostile for the monetizing that's
something I you know I want to add in
here because you've heard me say hustle
before hustle for the monetizing if
you've got a race card site or if you've
got you know a site about corn or if
you've got a site about gasoline prices
google that term and find the people
that are advertising on that left side
over there to rights left you know the
right side excuse me or on and go and
hit them up click it you know probably
made them some money i don't know if
that's true i don't know what you can do
there but you know find those
advertisers click it and send up an
email and tell her why you rock the
house hustle for your monetization
nothing's gonna come to you don't act
and let somebody else do it for you you
need to hustle for yourself especially
in the beginning phases and finally C&C
and that is content and community that
is the core of having anything valuable
you can be
greatest greatest hustler but if you're
substances crap a lot of people like oh
yeah you know Gary hustles a whole lot
but you know that's just thing you know
or self-promotion whatever you know what
if there was in substance nobody would
care if i didn't really know everything
about what not if i rephrase that
because i don't like it go I don't know
crap load about wine but there's you
know I know a lot enough I've got some
street cred right so I know what I'm
doing right and so if there wasn't
substance behind it if I hadn't been
building businesses before maybe this
wouldn't even make sense but when you
have a little substance it's not by
accident don't drink the haterade things
don't happen by accident if you have a
little substance people get respect it
so you got to make sure you have that
content down you need to know your stuff
don't go to a space you to understand
cuz the trend is going there that's some
bull crap do what you know and then
you've got a good community you gotta
give you've got to give and you've got
to give some more my friends answer
every email answer every lead shake
every hand go to every conference and
meet people because that's what it's
about you put these four pieces together
and some stuff is gonna go down and it's
coming this gold rush is on I'm not
kidding it's coming but you know what if
you don't have every one of those pieces
all for your dead so if you know if you
know it's coming and it's awesome but
you don't have the chops you know the
skills that content part you're not
gonna win I'm not gonna send you false
hope guys you know if you don't have the
goods in that subject matter nobody's
gonna care you're going to be exposed
but I can't leave on you're gonna be
exposed I gotta leave on it's gonna be
awesome as long as you recognize what
your passion is and what your content um
could be best about by understanding
what you do best